You never know what will
happen to a story like this.
You never know
how it will resonate.
You just pray.
To the Nordic gods,
of course.
If we wanted to describe...
basically you could say
the problems
that every young person
could actually
be facing in real life.
But, of course,
adding this supernatural
element to the story
that this young kid
actually has the makings
of a god inside him.
We have been looking at
the whole season.
That is basically the first
structure we're working on.
Where is Magne at the
beginning of the season,
where does he end?
And how do we split
this huge development
over a six
natural part structure.
That is the first structure
we're looking at.
Then we're delving into
every single episode.
And, of course,
in every single episode,
every single scene
and find our way the natural
structure for the episode.
Being a writer,
that very much likes this
gritty-realism
that is very significant
for much story telling
in the Nordic countries.
It was a joy for me
actually,
to go into
the supernatural genre
and all of the sudden,
you know, discussing
"Can this character fly?"
It was amazing,
to have all these
possibilities on your table.
At all times
you have to be focused
on the forces of antagonism.
That your main character
has enough against him.
One of the most
difficult things
to write about the show
was probably
the moment you begin to
put in supernatural elements
in a realistic world.
You really need to set up
all the rules about this.
Because how much
a god is he?
How far can his abilities,
where they are now,
actually take him?
There's a very important
theme in Ragnarok,
which is the environmental
theme.
We thought that was very
interesting to throw in.
Not only because
it is a very modern
element in all our lives,
so all these discussions
that they are actually
having in Ragnarok,
are very much discussions
that I'm having myself
on the private scene.
I think, as a writer,
it's extremely important
to remind yourself
at all times
that you cannot write
for everyone.
You cannot write a story
for 190 countries.
Because I think if you try
to write for everyone,
you will end up
writing for no one.
See you. Bye bye.